foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Albus Dumbledore and the
discovery he made in his youth that made
him famous I am of course talking about
his discovery of the 12 uses of dragon's
blood an alchemical feat worthy of a
place in the history books today when we
think of Dumbledore's achievements the
accomplishment that stands out most was
his 1945 defeat of dark wizard Gaelic
Grindelwald as he effectively saved the
Wizarding World from a perilous fate
after 1945 there wasn't a Wizarding
household in the world that didn't know
his name however what many don't realize
is that Dumbledore is also quite famous
from his other achievements in The
Wizarding World Dumbledore lived a long
time 115 years to be exact and during
his formative years he was able to
achieve a lot beginning to impress other
witches and wizards as early as the year
80 1893 in a matter of months albus's
own Fame had begun to Eclipse that of
his father by the end of his first year
he would never again be known as the son
of a muggle hater but has nothing more
or less than the most brilliant student
ever seen at the school
and for the remainder of Dumbledore
studies with his negative associations
now a thing of the past Dumbledore
continued to excel achieving every Ward
and Accolade imaginable Rita Skeeter
described this well in her book The Life
and lies of Albus Dumbledore now
approaching his 18th birthday Dumbledore
left Hogwarts in a blaze of glory head
boy prefect winner of the Barnabas
finkley prize for exceptional spell
casting British youth representative to
the wizard gamut and Gold Medal winner
for Grand breaking contribution to the
International alchemical Conference in
Cairo ilfius Doge Dumbledore's friend
had something to say as well he not only
won every prize of note that the school
offered he was soon in regular
correspondence with the most notable
magical names of the day Dumbledore had
achieved a lot and his name was
spreading like wildfire but his crowning
achievements other than defeating
Grindelwald that is had yet to come
after the death of his sister he decided
to take a trip to France where he
visited his old friend Nicola Flamel
Flamel was a famed Alchemist and it was
in France that Dumbledore studied the
Ancient Art and Science of alchemy under
his tuteland
after an unknown period of time
Dumbledore returned back to Britain and
it just so happened that in this time
period Dumbledore became infatuated with
the study of dragon's blood specifically
its uses a relatively Uncharted subject
in Wizarding culture
Dragon Blood was the blood of any of the
many species of dragon and it had 12
uses all of which Dumbledore discovered
and subsequently published earning him
widespread recognition Dumbledore was
now world famous but despite this
discovery catapulting Dumbledore to
stardom there are still a lot of
unknowns when it comes to Dumbledore's
Discovery at least from our perspective
while the uses of dragon's blood were
published in all sorts of alchemical
manuscripts we the Muckle readers have
never been enlightened as to what these
12 uses are today I want to dig in and
see what I can find on this subject
first things first what is dragon's
blood dragon's blood as you might have
expected was blood extracted from any
species of dragon a dark red glutinous
substance the blood of a dragon was
particularly powerful but also adaptable
which is why it was eventually
discovered to have so much practical
application in The Wizarding World it's
worth noting however that dragons
weren't the only magical creature with
powerful blood one sip of Unicorn Blood
could keep witches and wizards alive
even when they were an inch from death
but it did come with a big price tag a
condemnation to a cursed existence a
half-life drinking the blood of a rhem a
type of rare giant horse grunt the
Drinker immense strength for a short
period of time and the blood of a
Chillin a mythical creature that was
part dragon and part horse had the
ability to show people Visions it's
clear that the blood of certain magical
creatures has extremely powerful
capabilities but oddly enough the first
two uses of dragon's blood that I want
to discuss in this video sympheli
mundane by comparison one and two Steve
cloves revealed that two of the uses of
dragon's blood in an interview what kind
of things do you run by Rolling a range
of things even something really simple I
once asked about the 12 uses of dragon's
blood which is referenced in the books I
emailed her to ask and 25 seconds later
I got an email back with a list one is
an oven cleaner yes another is a spot
remover it was really amazing so kicking
things off we've got two rather
underwhelming answers an oven cleaner
and a way of getting rid of spots or
acne 3. the third and last confirmed use
of dragon's blood is that it can be used
to get rid of verrucas a type of wart
that appears on the soles of your feet
Believe It or Not these three mundane
uses are the only Canon confirmed
answers revealing what dragon's blood is
used for this leaves nine uses
outstanding with that said however I
happen to have nine of my own theories
for what these remaining uses may be
let's get into it 4. the fourth use of
dragon's blood that I want to highlight
is that it can be used to heal injuries
or at least ease the pain well that's my
theory anyway the basis for this Theory
stems from the Order of the Phoenix
where Hagrid places a dragon stake on
his face in order to ease the stinging
he felt from injuries that he had
sustained while visiting the giant
Colony it's entirely possible that
something else from the Dragon Meat was
helping but in my opinion it was most
likely the blood you're not going to eat
that are you hankered said Ron leaning
in for a closer look it looks poisonous
it's supposed to look like that it's
Dragon Meat Hagrid said and I didn't get
it to eat he'd pick up the steak and
slapped it of the left side of his face
greenish blood to trickle down into his
beard as he gave a soft moan of
satisfaction that's better it helps with
the stinging you know
number five my theory for the fifth use
of dragon's blood is simply that it has
the ability to mimic human blood in the
Half-Blood Prince horoscorn wipes
dragon's blood all of the walls of his
house to fake his own death and ward off
the Death Eaters when Dumbledore comes
to find him he asks Horus what type of
blood it was that he wiped on the walls
what kind of blood was that incidentally
I'll stumbledore loudly of the Charming
of the newly unsmashed grandfather clock
on the walls Dragon shouted the wizard
called Horus perhaps dragon's blood is
one of the closer Bloods to human blood
at least visually this one is certainly
a little more questionable particularly
as dragon's blood was referenced to be
green in the passage where Hagrid wipes
a stake on his face I don't know any
humans with green blood however there
are other instances in which it is
suggested that the blood is red perhaps
Hagrid just had the blood of one
particular breed of dragon 6. my sixth
theory for the use of dragon's blood is
that it is used as a potion strengthener
I actually saw some sources claiming
that this was a confirmed use but I
wouldn't go that far the main motivation
behind this theory is that Slughorn a
master potioneer was known to keep
Dragon blood in stock
alternatively it's entirely possible
that dragon's blood doesn't function as
a potion strengthener but instead as its
own potions ingredient one such potion
that I can imagine dragon's blood being
involved with is the pep Rock potion the
pepper up potion was used for two things
to cure the common cold and to warm
people up the potion had a side effect
of causing steam to emit from the
drinker's ears it seems only natural
that the blood from a dragon which is
synonymous with warmth and fire would be
an appropriate fit for this potion what
other potions can you think of that
could benefit from dragon's blood
comment below 7. with most of the
confirmed users discussed so far
dragon's blood has been used topically
or transdermally what this encourages me
to explore further are the oral uses of
dragon's blood what happens if you drink
it my next theory for dragon's blood is
that it can strengthen the drinker's
skin Dragon hides are notoriously strong
and resistant to most spells in fact it
would take 12 Wizards casting the
stunning spell all at once to even have
a chance at stunning it dragons are
extremely difficult to slay owing to the
ancient magic that imbues their thick
hides which none but the most powerful
spells can penetrate
I think the drinking dragon's blood
could do one of two things to your skin
one temporarily strengthen it to a
fairly significant degree helping with
spell resistance or two slowly
strengthen it over time if this is the
case the more Dragon Blood you drink the
stronger your skin would get this would
need to be done a very longer period of
time eight my next theory for dragon's
blood is that it can Aid in channeling
magic as we all know Dragon heart
strings are used as a core in some ones
typically powerful ones if we consider
the proximity of the Dragon heartstring
to the heart itself then it would make
sense that there is some hematological
connection between the heartstring and
blood however I would expect there to be
some sort of caveat to this particular
use namely that in order to have this
Boost from the dragon's blood you need
to have been chosen by a Dragonheart
string wand nine my next theory for drag
dragon's blood is that when ingested it
can be used as an antidiuretic this
usage isn't exactly pretty but given
that some of its uses are linked with
cleaning surfaces and removing pimples I
think that it would sort of make sense
that this miracle solution has the
ability to help ease a complaining
stomach 10. my next theory for dragon's
blood is that it can allow you to for a
very brief period of time breathe fire
the connection between fire and Dragons
is an obvious one so I won't dive into
it but the prospect of drinking Dragon
Blood allowing you to breathe fire just
feels right I don't imagine this to be a
sustained ability instead I like to
think that as soon as the dragon's blood
hits your stomach a single jet of fire
spurts out of the drinker's mouth 11. my
next theory is that drinking dragon's
blind brings you good fortune in many
cultures across the globe especially in
Chinese culture the dragon is looked at
as a symbol of luck and good fortune in
fact dragons are so highly regarded in
Chinese culture that many temples and
shrines have been dedicated to them in
Harry Potter there is a potion for good
luck aptly named liquid luck or Felix
felices but I like to imagine then
drinking dragon's blood would provide a
watered-down or slightly less effective
version of this popular potion the
drawback to this theory is that I
imagine a lot more people would have
been using it for this function in the
books 12. my last theory for dragon's
blood is a bit of a Hail Mary and that
that it can be used to grow your nails
dragons are well known for their strong
Talons and sharp spikes so I like to
imagine that it's entirely within the
realm of possibility for Dragon Blood
consumption to help strengthen your bone
Nails the idea behind ingesting an
animal's organs or fluids to gain its
power or inherit its trades falls under
are an anthropological concept called
contagious or sympathetic magic the
principle of contagious magic states
that personal energy can travel through
objects and that there is a permanent
relationship between an individual and
their body and with that last theory for
the uses of dragon's blood in mind I do
want to go back and discuss its history
a little bit as there's shockingly some
controversy regarding Dumbledore's claim
to fame it turns out that another wizard
by the name of evil dillonsby had
actually already been tackling the
subject for years and though Dumbledore
had been credited as discovering all 12
uses dylansby claimed that he had
already discovered eight uses before
Dumbledore borrowed his notes actually
dillonsby outright accused Dumbledore of
stealing them and he discussed all of
this in Rita Skeeter's book The Life and
lies of Albus Dumbledore now we know
that Dumbledore hasn't always made the
right to
open the best person I mean for goodness
sake he almost plotted to take over the
Wizarding World so I think it's entirely
plausible that Dumbledore did in fact
steal dillonsby's notes Dumbledore was
brilliant but he was also a bit of a
ruthless Cutthroat in his youth the
counter-argument to this however is that
Dylan's B was totally full of it and
just jealous of what Dumbledore was able
to achieve with that out of the way next
I want to segue into real life or muggle
dragon's blood that's right dragon's
blood is real in our muggle World
dragon's blood is actually the name for
a type of tree sap the name stemming
from its bright red color and as it so
happens real dragon's blood also has a
wide variety of uses all the way from
medicine to Art let's take a quick look
at 12 of the real life uses the first is
toothpaste in the 18th century the first
toothpaste using dragon blood was
created apparently dragon's blood has
been used in some cultures for centuries
to help treat teeth sensitivities and
gum recession next up is varnish
dragon's blood first started being used
as a Varnish in the 18th century by
Italian violin makers and it's actually
still used for that today it helps give
violins a deep rich red brown color next
is incense because of dragon blood's
strong smell it apparently makes an
excellent incense
next is perfume as I mentioned in the
previous Point dragon's blood has quite
a strong sand which makes it an
excellent choice for an ingredient in
perfumes it is supposed to have a strong
earthy scent next is ink due to Dragon
blood's distinctive deep red color it
can easily be transformed into a rich
ink it's been expressed that unlike
actual blood dragon's blood will retain
its bright red color after it is
finished drying next is Body Oil
dragon's blood has long been regarded as
helpful in reducing redness and
inflammation of the skin when converted
into an oil and applied topically it can
help to calm and soothe next is a
coagulant as it happens dragon's blood
is rich in a chemical compound called
Tas Bean which is a known coagulant that
has been documented to have
anti-inflammatory and wound healing
capabilities however with that said tasp
being is not used frequently in modern
medicine as it has not undergone
sufficient testing next is an antiviral
medicine taspin the compound I mentioned
earlier as well as proantho cyanidine
are both found in dragon's blood and are
natural antivirals
next is a cure for stomach problems
apparently there have been studies
completed on dragon's blood which have
shown that it can Aid with
gastrointestinal issues the result is
that dragon's blood can be found in some
pharmaceutical products next is a fever
reducer despite a lack of scientific
backing dragon's blood was used in
traditional medicine to help treat
fevers I'd be curious to see more
information and studies on this to
determine its validity next is a cure
for skin disorders this one lines up
with Harry Potter as in Harry Potter one
of the identified uses is a spot remover
apparently dragon's blood can help with
things like acne or eczema
last up we've got spells that's right
you heard me over the course of history
dragon's blood has long been associated
with the occult often used as a stand-in
for actual blood and that's it for this
video those are all of the confirmed and
theorized uses for dragon's blood in
both Wizarding culture and our own what
do you think of my theories for the uses
of dragon's blood what theories do you
have leave a comment down below also if
you enjoy the content please be sure to
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
foreign